hallo herzlich willkommen zu einem neuen
blog von uns und wir wie es kann in der
neuen wohnung in der küche
beziehungsweise in der wohnküche
ihr könnt sehen dass sich hier noch
nicht viel getan hat aber das kommt
alles wir haben schon die neuigkeit noch
instagram verkünden und zwar haben wir
unsere küche schon geplant dazu gibt es
aber ein extra video war ich weiß es
ganz viele von euch wissen wollten was
gibt es zu beachten oder worauf achtest
du genau und tipps und tricks zu küchen
planungen und deswegen habe ich gedacht
es ist total sinnvoll da ein extra video
zu machen und ich werde natürlich auf
jeden fall vorher noch eure fragen
willst weil ich morgen zum küchenstudio
fahrt um da ein bisschen zu drehen ich
habe auch schon gefragt es geht alles in
ordnung und sowieso total cool drauf das
ist nämlich der markus mit seinem papa
mit seinem bruder mit seinem
angestellten also richtig richtig cool
ich freue mich das schon total auf
ich hab noch zu sagen dass wir uns
gleich weil das muss also wir haben hier
in der küche also hier vorne die fliesen
die müssen sowieso erweitert werden weil
die küche die wir bis hierhin gehen
da wurde studio sind haben wir deswegen
aufgestellten gucken wollten und das
heißt man müsste eigentlich sowieso die
fliesen verlängern aber ganz viele von
euch haben auf instagram geschrieben
ganz viele fliesen fachverkäufer haben
wir geschrieben clique du wissen niemals
die gleichen fliesen filmen setzen die
gleichen finden wirst der farbton die
nordsee wird niemals gleich sein
also waren bisher meist dazu sind der
reparationen das ist mir ganz schön gut
sieht dann muss dazu ist aber nochmal zu
den fliesen wir möchten hier in
wohnküchen bereich komplett im boden
verlegen lassen das heißt wir wollen
hier komplett fiesen haben das
einheitlich ist und ich hatte sogar
überlegt dass wenn die haut also das
sofa später hier an der wandel ist also
das ist ja eine steinwand also will ich
richtig schön finden das ist mal so ein
akzent wir haben ja vom vermieter noch
eine steinwand im flur das zeige ich
euch und da hat der vermieter gefragt
das wegmachen ich weil ich finds richtig
schön also das ist das hier das ist wenn
man hier reinkommt die gegenüber ist
nämlich die eingangstüren und ich finde
es richtig schön ich habe mir nur wieder
schluss wohnzimmer weiße steine zu
nehmen hoffentlich gibt was nach seinem
geschmack schon mal gespannt was
vielleicht finden werden heute ist es zu
fassen ich bin so froh dass ich meine
wäsche von zu hause die habe ich vor
vier fünf tagen als ich hier bei der
wohnung habe ich die mitgebracht
gewaschen schnellen trockner getan
seitdem liegt das erst 45 tage und ich
war so voll dass ich das hier in der
neuen wohnung waschen trocknen und zu
hause haben wir kein trocken da muss ich
mal ist der hand aufhänge im keller und
dann dauert es immer drei tage bis es
trocknet so weiß der coach ist hier
warte ich auch drei vier tage bis ich
mal wieder in der wohnung bin so wir
sind gerade in mülheim fliesen sale in
zwar bin ich draufgekommen durch die
liebe nori anori verlinkt euch mal ihre
seite in die infobox so eine süße maus
und sie hat ja auch ihre friesen
gekauften habe ich doch so kalkuhl hat
mir gefallen gucke ich auch noch was es
so schön es gibt
manchmal zeige ich euch auf instagram
das wohl meiner eltern und da fragen
immer ganz ganz viele was sind das für
fliesen und das denn eigentlich exakt
diese hier die habe ich vorhin auch
schon gesehen die gibt es ja auch in den
maßen ebene eltern haben nämlich 80 mal
80 soweit ich weiss oder 60 mal 60
jedenfalls quadratisch und ich bin ja
verliebt in solche fliesen
haben sie machen soll und ich machen
blog wir haben uns jetzt gut beraten
lassen von murat und ich frage gleich
mal habt ihr euch mal die wichtigsten
tipps und tricks mit geben kann ob er
lust hat dann noch vor der kamera zu
sprechen und dann sagt ihr euch die
wichtigsten monate eine frage kannst du
mal zu schauen so die 12 wichtigsten
tipps geben zum friesen kauf bis das
machen
euro zufließen ziel kommen erst mal her
konzept sehr genau euch gibt's jeden
mutai und außerdem also uns gibt ist
eben kamen und unsere dürfte für den
bitkom kommen die zwei drei wichtigsten
tipps zu frieden gehabt was muss man
beim krisen kaufen achten
es gibt drei er bei diesen arten oder
ecken sage ich mal gibt es fließen die
riskante haben das bedeutet nach dem
brand vorgang wenn die aus dem ofen
rauskommen werden die fliesen gerade
geschrieben dazu sagt man qualifiziert
dann gibt es eine art hat die ecken wo
diese phase habe nach dem brand fordert
werden wir viel mehr geschnitten und je
nachdem aus welchem land wir herkommen
schützeberg gibt es ihren erkannt oder
ganz leichte phase beinhaltet
verschiedene wo man beim kauf achten
schneidet man hat man sie in der ersten
phase das heißt und sie ist ein helles
scherben und da muss man dann halt drauf
achten wenn du sagst okay dann muss man
halt bei verfugen darauf achten dass das
schön bündig geschlossen wird das ist
zum beispiel eine fiese was hat das
erhaltene phase hat das sollte man das
ja jetzt bei der für diese machen wir
gerade bei der alten serie dass sie
hatten gerade schnitt da ist diese
regisseure wirkung dann richtig abheben
genau das wird unsere wiese sein dass
ich die eigene serie noch eine hellere
davon genau ein helleres und ein
dunkleres modell das ist hier das wäre
mir jetzt so dunkel deswegen haben wir
uns für das mittlere entschieden und ich
habe vorhin diese fliesen gesehen die
für mich so schön aber dass dann
irgendwann mal wenn wir uns wirklich ein
haus kaufen sollten dann werden die
fliesen meine erste wahl
demnach wird gerade das alten gewünscht
war
wenn euch gefällt
das nicht empfehle ich jedem kunden
muster zu regulieren will kostenlos egal
welches das hört man noch gerne also
würde ich auf jedem rasen einfach
mitnehmen noch mal zu hause daran halten
ob es wirklich passt dann seid ihr auf
der sicheren seite so machen wir es auch
wichtig für die kinder wenn die eltern
mit kindern kommen können sich
zurückziehen spielen war das denn wie
auch immer die eltern können
[Musik]
so bist du bereit
warum lasse ich das tragen was nicht
schwer
komm wir tauschen ich denke zu sagen wie
diese typischen ausländer
der vorlauf mit flüssiggas an was guckst
du was guckst du und die produkte waren
die besten sendungen
was muss das muss getankt werden muss
halt auch mal schreiben ist es so
geregelt eine tankfüllung hansa einig
das ist früher wären wir das
küchenmobiliar seit etwas mehr als einem
jahr und ist es so dass total egal
wir haben uns ja jetzt um so fließen
ausgesucht das heißt wir haben die mit
dem gepäck bedürften die mit dem assist
olle der murat hat nämlich gesagt egal
was für was ihr euch entscheidet seit
schlau nimmt euch die friesen hier
kostenlos mit natürlich bringen wir nie
wieder zurück aber wir können die halle
kostenlos mitnehmen und es ist ein
riesenvorteil
wenn man dann auch gerne wieder hält die
somit wenn man genau haben will
aber es springt auch von diesen einst
hoch deswegen habe ich immer kein geld
im auto und ich stecke mir so es ist
doch die mit tag riesen sache jetzt so
halbwegs erledigt und jetzt gehen wir
etwas futter werden erst mal gedacht wir
haben nämlich so noch im magen des
tieres kommen wir gucken was es hier so
eine nähe gibt was man diese essen kann
und dann haben wir gedacht
erstmal werden die schwiegermutter
angerufen meine mama hat fish gemacht
haben sie mal kein fisch haben sie es
noch mal hat das mitgemacht haben sagt
resch deswegen gehen wir jetzt so haben
sie nach hause und essbares haben wir
uns geld gespart ist gesünder und
leckerer
[Musik]
vorbei die zeit in dem man mir hier
kaffee machte
schön war es am anfang
das haben sie sich noch bemühte gesagt
ja klar früher immer wie verwirrt kann
ein mensch eigentlich sein zu machen die
rückkamera kann ist er mir hier so wie
hier und dieses original zehn jahre alt
es ist mein alter genommen
also hör dir fragt ob jetzt fahren wir
schauen uns jetzt die premiere von anita
an das ist ein kinofilm in englische
originalversion ist eigentlich ganz gut
ich kann zu englisch aber ich wollte
mein englisch verbessern und habe mir
schon überlegt wie kann man sein
englisch verbessern einfach filme auf
englisch gucken so mit sich dass ich
glaube ich besser und wir fahren da
erzählt wir haben damals gewann frische
gefahren sollte man so etwas mitgemacht
und ich haben wird natürlich mit dem
richtig
ihr neues amt ist die einzige pro park
soll jetzt haben wir schon popcorn und
nachos geholt und getränke die waren
alle gratis und dann habe ich mir mal im
kino so schreck oh schreck die teuren
sms gegönnt die auf 50 1 christina bock
schade aber nicht gesehen ich will es
mal klar stellen jetzt das war einfach
nur ein job
ich wollte einfach nur ärgerlich war die
leute ein bisschen unterhalten
ich sagte mit diesen lärm versorgen so
wieder raus
[Musik]
ich gehe doch brautkleid so bitte was
fliesen angekommen ich zeige euch mal
wenzel
ich freue mich schon richtig drauf der
selbst ist noch draußen es müssen jetzt
so alles rein holen und ich glaube ich
geht aber erstmal wasser und brötchen
kaufen weil wir haben hier gar nichts
nix alles lernen komm schon du schaffst
du also es ist schwerer als es aussieht
sagen wir mal so was hab ich kann alles
hoch getragen und haben so macht die
großen fließen
und weil die ball hat nicht gereicht hat
gehe ich jetzt noch etwas wichtiges zu
frühstücken holen
eines der dinge die ich nie verstehen
werde warum werden guten extra noch mein
folie verpackt so schlecht für die
umwelt und im endeffekt gesichter keinen
mehrwert da drin
ich mache das was hat man davon mal
mächtiger doch sowieso um diesen
aufkleber hat man ja auch entweder auf
die gurken kleben können oder ganz
einfach beschildern können muss ich mich
verstehen aber jetzt erst mal richtig
frühstücken
schaut mal das wollte ich euch noch
zeigen als ich in marrakesch war hat der
haben sich diesen bilderrahmen geholt
und sie haben inzwischen gezeigt aber
nicht jeder volkmer dort und zwar hat er
sich überlegt hier so eigentlich haben
soll muss das umgekehrt sein also das
ist von der islamisch noch zeit die
bayer als erstes danach kam das
standesamt und hier fehlt nur noch ein
bild von hochzeit
[Musik]
unsere geliefert wir haben hier auch den
boden komplett verlegt wo menschen die
kamera um so der boden wurde verlegt
schaut euch meinen fliesen an
ich liebe dieses muster und das gleiche
ist jetzt hier auch der rückwand das ist
ein toller ausgleich zu dem was ich
bisher hatte
zwar ist das muss da drin aber es ist
nicht mehr ganz so bunt und das tolle
ist ich kann jetzt auch mal gemusterte
oberteile tragen bunte oberteile tragen
die rückwand immer eine diva diva
richtig kunterbunt und tier ist alles
schön neutral dann kann ich mit meinen
oberteilen machen was ich will ich kann
deko hinstellen wie ich will
ich freue mich auf jeden fall richtig
und zeige ich euch noch mal ganz kurz
den einblick in die küche wird dabei die
stehen und hier wo ich stehen nimmt der
hamster dann auf und was sagst du so zur
küche ja das war das wort verändert und
wir warten jetzt auf die küchen monteure
bis die sonne bekommt einen
küchenmonteur zusammen mit dem markus
dettenkofer auf dem küchenstudio blog
bzw des wahlkampfs sondern erst
richtiges info video und genau
privat ist braucht und wir können ein
zeitvergleich abspielen lassen wollte
das mal sehen ich mag das volk ich liebe
zeitraffer ihr könnt ihr gar nicht
antworten ok derzeit einfach kommt im 21
das nächste treffen helfen leben kaputt
macht
[Musik]
die arbeit gemacht
was soll man von draußen kommt ist die
bude heraus
ich habe mir gerne in die kommentare was
bestimmte fragen beantwortet
wir verraten
nicht ganz freiwillig